MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, my
name is Martin Omander,
and I welcome you to
the Root Access Show.
Today, I'm joined by Waleed
Abdulla, founder of Ninua.
Thanks for coming in
here today, Waleed.
WALEED ABDULLA:
Thank you, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: Tell
us a bit about Ninua.
What does your startup do?
WALEED ABDULLA: So
we have two products,
Symphony at symphonytools.com.
It's a social media
management dashboard
for businesses to publish
to multiple social networks
at the same time
and also to listen
to what their customers
say about them
on these social networks.
And the second is
Network to Blogs,
which is a platform for bloggers
to distribute and promote
their blogs and to network
with other bloggers.
It has about 1.2
million bloggers on it.
And it's active-- been
going on for a few years.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So for a few years?
Had did Ninua get started?
WALEED ABDULLA: So Network to
Blog started in a hackathon.
This was one of those events
where you go on Friday,
build a product, and launch
it by the end of Sunday.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
WALEED ABDULLA: So
that's how it started.
It was a side project.
It was not planned
to be a startup.
And then it kind
of grew over time
and started gaining
more traction.
At some point, we were getting
a thousand bloggers signing up
every single day.
We have a total of 4.2
million blogs on it
and about 7 million users-- 1
million monthly active users.
So somehow it just happened.
It wasn't planned.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's great.
The best things in life are
often the unexpected ones,
right?
So now you have this product
that attracts a lot of users
and you hadn't really
planned for it.
What was your first
business model?
WALEED ABDULLA: So we
started with advertising
just like a lot of startups do.
We put AdSense on it,
and then after a while,
we started looking into other
options like other networks
and kind of experimented with
trying to sell ads directly.
That didn't scale as
we wanted, though.
We had millions of
page views, but we
didn't have tens of
millions of page views.
So with a few millions
of page views,
you can make good revenue.
You can cover your costs
and maybe pay a salary.
But to build a
business that scales,
you need tens or hundreds
of millions of page views,
and we did not have that.
We worked a lot on trying
to increase engagement,
but at the same
time, we also knew
that we were targeting
a niche of bloggers.
So after a lot of
experiments, we
realized that
probably this will not
scale to hundreds of
millions of page views.
So that's when we started
looking at other options.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
and getting enough money
for one salary is nice, but
not enough to build a business
and grow the business.
WALEED ABDULLA: Exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER: So when
you hit that realization,
it was time to rejigger
the business model.
What did you do?
WALEED ABDULLA: So we tested
as well paid features.
So the product is free, and we
added a few additional features
that you can pay for.
It was a low dollar
level payment plans,
like $5 per month
or $20 per month.
And we experimented with that.
It wasn't our focus.
We were still focusing on
optimizing advertising.
But that continued to grow
as well and at some point
was generating more
revenue than ads.
Actually, it was
like 2 to 1 ratio.
So finally we thought, OK, maybe
for our business it fits better
to monetize it with a paid
system rather than advertising.
And then we decided
to focus on that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So now you have
the business model
of-- the ads are
still there, you
have the new model
that is the way
to go with paid
premium features.
A decision to make here, right?
Did you create a new company?
Did you create a new
product or a new brand?
What did you end up doing
and what was your thinking
going into this decision?
WALEED ABDULLA: Yeah.
So it was the same team
and the same technology,
so we kept the same company.
But the new customer segment
was small businesses.
And small businesses don't
identify as bloggers.
And the name, Network
to Blog, lends itself
to a blogging related tool.
So even if a
business has a blog,
they think of themselves as
a business, not as a blogger.
So we decided to go
with a different name,
and that's how we
ended up with Symphony.
We took the same source
code, then modified it,
copied and modified it,
to launch a new product.
We removed a lot of the features
that are specific to Network
to Blogs, to the social
aspects of Network to Blogs,
and kept the features that
are more useful to businesses,
and then built on that.
And then we ended up
with the new product.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
that's interesting.
Tell me a little
bit more of that.
So you had this one product,
this one codebase, and then
you needed to have this
business-focused version.
But you had the millions
of consumers as well.
So you forked the codebase?
So what did you do?
WALEED ABDULLA: Yes.
Exactly.
So we forked the codebase,
we had a new code base,
and made a lot of changes
of the second version of it
that became the new product.
MARTIN OMANDER:
The business one?
WALEED ABDULLA: The Symphony.
And then we continued to grow
both of them independently.
There's a lot of overlap, but
from a user point of view,
they're completely different.
There are some common
features, but they
are very different products.
They look different,
they behave different,
and they target different
segments of users.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, so you
can put new consumer features
into the consume
product over here,
and new business features,
premium features, over here.
Ah, I see.
So with millions of users,
consumer bloggers or people
who identify as bloggers
rather than businesses,
how did you plan for going
and hitting this new customer
segment-- the small businesses?
WALEED ABDULLA: So we started
with our existing users, which
was the easiest thing to do.
So we put links on
our Network to Blogs.
We put the ads on
there that point people
to the new product, emailed some
of them, and started that way.
And then over time, we started
learning about new ways
to reach this new
segment of users.
And it's a new segment, so
there are different ways
to reach them.
And we are learning
as we go every day,
so it's still a
continuing journey.
MARTIN OMANDER: Every day is
a learning experience, right,
in a startup?
WALEED ABDULLA: Definitely true.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Thank you so much for sharing
your experiences with us,
Waleed.
WALEED ABDULLA:
Thank you, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hope
you find something
useful for your startup in here.
So please leave comments on the
show in the YouTube comments
section.
We read everything you write.
Also, if you're in a
startup, you should go
to
developers.google.com/startups
and see how Google
can help your startup.
With that, thank you,
and see you next time.